I want to start with congrats I've seen
all Eight Episodes uh I would be shocked
if this is not picked up for a season
two oh
thank you
so one of the things that I enjoyed is
that right at the beginning you have two
sisters fighting when you read that in
the script are you excited are you like
how the F am I gonna film this uh I
personally was so excited the SEC I love
physical acting so I love when I get to
do something that's not dialogue and
tell that story with physical comedy and
that was probably one of my favorite
filming days no one will ever know how
long it took but
yeah it was brutal but in the best way
that was easily one of my favorite days
on set
insane oh my God I read that I was like
what
am I allowed to say that there's a titty
twister
but it was just so much fun actually and
she was such a great partner on set she
was always checking in and like you need
water or anything and so it was actually
it was really fun we had a lot of fun we
did intense one of the things that I
commend the show is that it deals with
real issues while also having fun
um and so for all of you can you sort of
talk about that aspect like what did you
really most enjoy about the scripts yeah
I think that's one of the most important
and entertaining parts of free Ridge is
that it's like the the heartfelt moments
are so surprising that they're so much
more meaningful because you're like
wrapped up in this comedy in this Brash
humor and then you're hit with something
that's like really real and relatable
and it almost just like surprises you
and hits you in the gut and I think
that's what like one of the most special
parts of the series
yeah I think when everyone thinks of our
show it'll definitely be a comedic show
on the first sight yeah um but there are
definitely definitely a lot of heartfelt
moments that I think will catch a lot of
people by surprise and those were
honestly like some of the most fun parts
to film
um I mean the comedic parts are always
fun too but um yeah our show just has a
little bit of everything so yeah
and especially with uh the ages that
we're playing I think a lot of
people are gonna really appreciate the
representation and the topics that we
touch on that you don't really see you
know teenagers going through that
process of figuring out those things in
high school and I think that's something
that a lot of people are going to love
to see you know us going through that
together I love learning about the
behind the scenes the making of a show
or a movie so for soon to be fans of the
series uh what do you think they would
be surprised to learn about the actual
making of the show oh that's fun you
know how how well we got along I'm I'm a
little honest
I'm fighting with everybody I'm doing
all these I'm sorry I'm not sorry
we I love these people I promise I'm
nice to them in real life yeah I
actually love them yes we were just
giggle buddies yeah we're all just just
giggling that's the only word I can use
to describe it because we giggle like
these are like giggle buddies
can I say it one more time
four of us speaking of giggling
um which of you is the quickest to break
and which of you is the is the toughest
to get to laugh oh toughest easily Kayla
yeah
my characters she said she's running for
me laughing at me literally yeah the
easiest yeah either yeah
you bring us all down with you yeah once
it starts it's not going to end
yeah it's actually those 3 A.M shoots
yeah
the first season is Eight Episodes and
for each of you I'm curious which of the
eight was your favorite and why well oh
okay I thought about this a lot
um three and five are my favorites three
absolutely hilarious getting to do that
fight scene with Gloria that was I mean
that was just so much fun and that was a
whole night shoot so we were all so
delirious and there were a lot of like
background around so a lot of energy and
then five is just really fun because
um it's the the house party episode and
there's just a lot going on on each of
our own storylines but they all kind of
connect at the end and I think it's just
I don't know it's just really fun
yeah I think we share a lot of the same
favorite episodes five is definitely one
of the top
um that was really hectic as well it was
a whole party scene and it felt like a
party on set in good ways and bad
um so I would probably say five as well
if I had to pick one I think episode
three for me yeah that the house that we
shot in is insane it was so cool to be
this like art all over the wall
and it was actually just like party
scenes there's a lot of people yeah
I'm gonna come in with a
I personally loved episode four
um but for a very personal reason I feel
like that's where
um a lot of enes's layers come out and
you peel back a lot and you learn a lot
about why she is the way that she is and
her walls come down and I think that was
a really special moment it was also the
first moment in my career where I've
been able to actually do a dramatic
scene and um which she killed yeah thank
you
I'm curious which of you do you think is
closest to the character you play in
real life you know what I mean like yeah
as the personalities
no question
why
you're like what would you care to
elaborate
yeah
dummies and Sierras your turn
you walk into Sierra's room Chris
on her
oh my God it's true
that's fair
[Laughter]
on that note I gotta rap I'm just gonna
say like like I said I know this is
going to be a hit uh congrats and um
good luck with the rest of your speed
dating